so if you're an Apple fan you know that
September is huge for brand-new Apple
products but with covert 19 happening
this year things have been pushed a
little further back what's going on guys
my name is Everett homage and welcome
back to the channel today we're talking
about the brand new iOS 14 all the
rumors and all the leaks that have come
out to date as I record this it is the
7th of June 2020 which means in a couple
of weeks that Apple Worldwide Developers
Conference is going live on the 22nd of
June for the first time around the globe
usually it is an in-person event that
costs about $1,500 to attend however
this year with the madness and the
pandemic they are doing all things free
online for everybody to watch so if
that's something that interests you be
sure to check out my channel during that
time to get all the latest updates but
for now let's get into all the rumors of
iOS 14 and the huge change it has to
your iPhone so if you have any recent
Apple flagship device you know they just
pushed out the brand new ISO 13.5 point
one this update is purely a security
patch if you've had I Oh s thirteen
point five many many people have already
jailbroken that version to allow you to
get free paid apps all sorts of
different tweaks and features different
themes and basically that you can figure
it a little bit more like a Samsung or
Android device jailbreaking your device
is against apples regulations so I don't
recommend it it will void your warranty
if they're able to find out if it gets
bricked or something along those lines
so if you don't have to do it or if you
don't know what you're doing
pretty much don't do it but yeah that's
the reason Apple hasn't released
thirteen point five point one two just
fix up a few security issues but iOS 14
is a huge change to the device so
something that's stayed consistent since
day one of the iPhone is the home screen
the simplicity of it they user-friendly
nature of it but now it is rumored that
iOS 14 will push out a whole new array
of features for the home screen
we're talking a list view of all the
apps ordering them by most-used
or even via the ones that have the most
notifications and even potentially
including widgets onto your home screen
now if you're on an android user and
you've never used an android before you
probably don't know what widgets are but
we just basically allow you to order
your homescreen how you like something
they can give you kind of a good
indication of what this is on an Apple
device is on an iPad if you swipe across
to a notification center and you have
the different section underneath like
whether battery life of the pencil of an
iPad things like that that's a widget
built into the native ISO an update like
this would really allow you to have
bitten freedom and customization in your
home screen you could have the weather
permanently at the bottom and alarm
clock all sorts of different features
that Android users have had the liberty
and luxury of for many many years but
the downside to this in my personal
opinion is the simple fact it isn't an
iPhone anymore it is a more complex
device to use it isn't user friendly for
all people across the spectrum so for
somebody that's a little bit older and
has never used too much technology in
their lifetime an Apple device is
perfect because it is so user friendly
for a newer user it probably isn't too
much of a big deal but I know personally
I always recommend iPhones and Apple
devices to people who have never used
technology before because it's so easy
to pick up and it's so intuitive
all these extra tech features are going
to make it a bit tricky and a bit harder
for the older generation to learn how to
use this device so even though this is a
great feature that has been rumored and
personally I would love to see it an
iPhone I don't know if this is a good
business decision from Apple side of
things because most of their market is
anybody between 18 all the way to 60 75
something that also will be very handy
and very helpful to people on an iPhone
is the fact that it's rumored you're
going to be able to change your default
open applications so for example if you
open something on Safari for Google Maps
for example and it automatically takes
you to Apple maps you didn't have the
ability to change that previously now
you're going to have
the ability to change it two ways Google
Maps or whatever other map software you
want to use this is going to be the same
feature across the spectrum so if you
want to use potentially word instead of
notes or whatever like that you should
have the ability to change this now the
next room at update is something we're
all accustomed to in other apps iPhone
messaging system is predicted to get an
at person directory so if you're in a
group message I'm going to go at John
he's going to be able to simply target
that person so they get a direct
notification we're all used to this in
facebook Messenger and whatsapp so it's
about time they caught up you're also
going to have the ability to retract
messages if somebody hasn't seen it
you're probably going to be able to get
rid of it before they do and you're also
going to be able to mark messages as
unread so you can come back to them
later and not lose your place that's
personally very handy for me because I
do that with emails all the time I'll
read an email Girt and that's pretty
important I want it to be notified I
wanted to stay in my notifications list
so just mark it as unread the next
feature has been promised for a while
now and that's multitasking multitasking
is more than likely going to be coming
to the iPads more so than the iPhones
because the real-estate size but it will
be good to see them on all devices
across the board multitasking on an
iPhone and iPad is a very simple feature
that is again available to all Android
devices already so for example on my S
20 I can simply open two apps
split-screen top to bottom or side to
side and run them simultaneously this is
a very handy feature to use for
productivity personally I don't use it
too much I don't see the real estate on
a phone being optimized for it they're
an iPad it would definitely be very
useful I do use it on the iPad already
which is a little bit of a different
multitasking app but it works really
really well now another feature that's
going to be coming to a safari platform
and across the board to the Apple native
apps is direct translate so if you've
used Google Chrome before and
accidentally go onto a website that
isn't in your native language it'll
automatically ask you to translate
Safari now on the other hand is going to
allow you to
do this straight away without having to
worry about internet data or anything
like that it's gonna have the ability to
natively translate this into your native
language through the iOS this is also
going to be seen in places like the App
Store where people leave reviews in
other languages or potentially even on
Instagram and Facebook where somebody's
bio might be a little bit different and
you might not understand what it says
so it'll automatically translate this
and be able to do it without internet
which is again a very very good and
useful feature sticking to the native
kind of updates inside the iOS and
that's the update for the Apple pencil
the Apple pencil will now begin to
support drag-and-drop functionality so
for an example if you're filling out a
time line on a website or you need a
click drag and drop or click drag and
release something with the Apple pencil
you haven't really had perfect ability
to do that until now so with the iOS 14
update we're gonna have the ability to
click drag drag align all the way to the
bottom release and have it interact just
like a mouse and I think this has come
through the native integration of the
new iOS iPad Mouse integration with the
new pointer so all these features are
slowly starting to make iPads and
iPhones a little bit more like a
computer something that is a bit of a
covert friendly feature and would have
been great to have a few months ago is a
brand new PT inbuilt into your iPhone so
very soon you're going to have a PT
that's able to coach you in swimming
running lifting all sorts of exercises
that generally require a coach this can
also be implemented into Apple TV so for
example if you're in your living room
want to do some yoga want to do some
Pilates or want to just get a quick 15
minute hit workout in you're going to
have your own personal trainer ready to
go I think this is a really really cool
app and something I definitely look
forward to exploring in the near future
and finally this is a very big update so
I apologize for the length of the video
however the last update I'm going to
talk about today
is Apple car key now Apple car key is
definitely a luxury update for the more
privileged user I guess if iPhones are
already a privilege device car key
allows you to start unlock lock your car
without having your car key it works on
the same principle that mobile payment
system work and near-field communication
works it runs through the near-field
communication chip and allows you to
pass that data across without having any
major security patches so with iOS 14
and the new updates your SmartWatch for
example will be able to potentially open
your brand-new car in the future at the
moment it looks like only BMW are
looking at releasing and implementing
this feature into their lineup of cars
no car in the world has Apple car key
yet but it will be definitely a feature
to look out for in the future when
buying a car if you're already
integrated in the Apple ecosystem car
manufacturers like Range Rover have
already started manufacturing their own
smart wrist bracelets to be able to
unlock a car without having your keys on
you so for example if you're going out
for a run and going for a swim at the
beach you don't have to worry about
taking your keys having them stolen
you're going to be able to just use that
key tag so with Apple coming into the
game and changing it once again bringing
that near-field communication into your
SmartWatch or into your phone that
you're already going to be using and
more than likely taking with you to the
beach or for a run is a much much better
way than purchasing another device so it
is that ideology of really integrating
everything into a smart world through
the Apple ecosystem anyway that's all
for me today guys I hope you enjoyed the
video I really look forward to telling
you more about the iOS 14 update On June
22nd when they give us a developer beta
release and then hopefully in October
potentially they've already said it's
going to be delayed so it won't set in
September the new iPhone 12 update and
all
for iOS 14 features release to the
public if you enjoyed the video make
sure you smash that subscribe button
2020 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday